that criminal network that we busted in
they were part of a network that was
responsible for up to 18 000 unaccounted
for elephants [ __ ] yeah you believe that
[ __ ] it's bad there have been many
assassinations of
individuals and leaders within
conservation those that make a
difference you've got a bounty on your
head
[Music]
i really appreciate you guys being here
today big part of the show is uh
bringing on folks who who who really
walk the walk don't just talk about it
and um you guys are are both 100 uh
those people but i just want to express
just real gratitude for you guys being
here and i'm not the best at at
introductions uh so if you guys could if
you guys could could you just you know
tell me your names and sort of tell me a
little bit about who you are um and um a
little bit about uh your organization
bet paul sure so uh my name is ryan tate
i'm the president and founder of vet
paul which is veterans empowered to
protect african wildlife
um i started the organization after i
served in the u.s marine corps
i also served in the u.s department of
state
and i just watched the documentary and
it really hit me hard and decided i want
to do something about it and that was
about eight years ago what was the
documentary that you saw it was a
documentary on one of the the major uh
news channels i was actually watching
anthony bourdain's parts unknown uh god
rest and
um
and i was i wasn't tired so i was like
well i'll see what's on next
as far as my animal involvement at the
time
i used to go to local animal shelters to
volunteer it helped with my you know
ptsd and therapy and things like that
and so i would take pictures of the
animals photography is a big passion of
mine and it would help their adoption
rate on the website
i already had two adopted cats and 125
pound rottweiler in my new york city
apartment so there were no more no more
uh room for animals
but uh yeah so i i'm the type of person
where
if i
i know that animal abuse exists in
cruelty i don't want to see it because i
know it's there
and if i can't do something about it why
i put myself through that i just
i don't know i guess my parents just
raised me to be compassionate for the
voiceless and the innocent and animals
are that and
and so i watched this documentary after
uh parts unknown was on
and uh
yeah i was not prepared to see what i
saw
what specifically if you can't like what
specifically was it in that documentary
that really got you there's three things
it was it was a uh
i mean it was three gut punches in a row
one there was a massive bull elephant
missing its tusk's entire face brain
matter all over
the tar road
the trunk is sitting separately from the
body like 10 feet away i mean it was
gruesome
the next scene was park rangers laying
dead and the third scene was video
footage
of a female rhino
that poachers had darted with a
tranquilizer that they got off the black
market because tranquilizer guns don't
go bang so nobody can hear it
so they darted her she went to sleep
they hacked her horn off through the
flesh 45 seconds
and then they were out
then she wakes up from the tranquilizer
and her calf
newborn babies is gone in the bush
and
they're waiting on veterinarians to get
there i mean you can't really save an
animal after it's had its
face cut off i mean i wouldn't want you
to save me if it was me
and so anyways while they're waiting for
the veterinarians we just watched this
this rhino die
i mean there were literally tears coming
down its eyes it was confused
and like all that ptsd and stuff you
you know get as a result of war i just
kind of shoved it in a glass jar super
glued it shut i'm like i'm good i'll
just deal with it
and that rhino was
the last straw and it just shattered
that jar i was crying like a baby snot
coming down my face and
pissed off i felt everything that that
animal felt
and i i had to do something about it and
knowing that park rangers are dying at
the same time
i just can't i can't deal with that and
where do you go from there i mean
knowing that you have to do something
about it you found this kinship to these
park rangers can you explain that and
then explain what your next steps were
yeah so i i was still at the u.s
department of state
i was not a foreign affairs advisor
the state department can be territorial
rightfully so i mean you're dealing with
with relationships with other countries
so i pissed off a a ton of people doing
research on this
tell them who you were protecting you
tell them who you were protecting
because it was a high level um no i
worked with uh senior state department
leadership um
but
and you're working you were working for
him at security or you were yeah i was
on the security details um
i had an assistant secretary of state
come up to me and say and this is on a
friday she said
with her whole entourage
i was at president obama's advisory
council
for wildlife trafficking an open forum
where they were talking about what the
us is going to do
to help stop poaching and wildlife
trafficking which is a top five
international crime
and so i took leave off of work went to
dc
and i was there as a private citizen she
knew who i was and on this on a friday
she said if you don't stop
what you're doing right now you will not
have a job on monday
and so i stormed out there pissed off as
all hell like who does this chick think
she is
and um i turned in my resignation papers
on monday and and look now i got
all right i got too many [ __ ]
questions but but why why why why why
what what what's her what what so why
did she say that their response was
we don't understand
what skills us veterans have that
translate to counter poaching
and that's disgusting to me
i mean that that just shows that okay
you're tasked with focusing on this
challenge and you don't know how bad it
is over there you don't know that
criminal networks militarized um
terrorist groups are doing the poaching
i mean
it's nuts i really want to go into the
connection between both organized crime
terrorism also but like especially at
first in tanzania you hand in your
resignation letter and then what's next
what happens then it's oh [ __ ] what do i
do now right
um no i just started going to africa um
a lot of it on my my own dime you know
we weren't even uh i don't think we got
our 501c3 until
you know
eight months later um so yeah just
started going over and observing i'm not
gonna go in with american flag i mean
i've got an american flag tattooed on my
chest
but i'm not gonna be leading the way you
know freedom fighters and my way or the
highway because a lot of americans go to
africa and
you know a lot of organizations and they
just
that style doesn't work
and when they leave it it damages those
of us that are there is that is that
knowledge or that insight is that
something that you you garnish is that
something that you learned in
overseas in the middle east 100
and can you can you explain that
parallel i mean at the end of the day
listen poachers are criminals they
just because they're poaching animals
doesn't mean that's all that they do to
make money they traffic humans drugs
they commit terrorist activities um arms
stealing you name it i mean
they are bad people these networks at
least and they're taking advantage of
locals
and it's very similar to what we did and
experienced in the middle east it's it's
these large powerful
um
bullies of criminal networks terrorist
networks that come in and they exploit
the community
what the us military is really good at
is taking a large area of operation
massive area of operation
and
successfully managing
operations within it with small teams
small unit tactics we were teaching
these guys how to utilize cover and
concealment um intelligence gathering
and exploitation
field trauma medicine
you name it leadership and it go and
what's crazy
is that these park rangers were so
stoked that a us marine is here they are
so well versed
in the wars in the middle east and the
fact that
we're here with our skills to help you
with your job they were like we're
important
wow what we are doing is is actually
very honorable to have guys like this
coming here absolutely originally you're
going over there to basically train and
then help facilitate the work of the
rangers uh it's a group of u.s veterans
who served in the middle east and you
know in that group you've got purple
heart recipients bronze star uh
recipients i mean can you talk about the
initially the group of people that you
went over with how that group was formed
what i know is from the tv show on
discovery but like was that the first
group that went out
that was the first full team group
before that um oz who's on the show
green beret 18 delta one of my best
friends he's amazing guy
um it was me and him we were doing a ton
of undercover ivory buys and things like
that and how did you two connect and how
did you find this sort of honestly he
just reached out to me one day and was
like hey i've been to africa and i've
done some counter poaching found your
group i just love to support you [ __ ]
you and so we started a relationship and
the rest was kind of history we just we
were
mark myself and oz we're all on the same
level of thinking
about how we're going to do things it's
not
it's not a one size fit all right and
we're doing this not to make money we're
not doing this for egos we're doing this
because we actually want to make a
difference absolutely vap didn't want to
go in there like well we're here to make
a difference right it was we're here to
support the tanzanian anti-wildlife
crimes task force at the time which is
is that the rangers
so we actually helped form the task
force it was the first ever uh wildlife
crimes task force so it's it was
intelligence-based
so we we actually hand-picked we did a
whole interview process with them we
hand-picked each member of that
15-person team so their job was to
go and do undercover buys and collect
information and then exploit that so we
can go and and take these guys down i
mean again man i have so many [ __ ]
questions but because so much of it
is
it kind of depends on this sort of like
undercover work you don't have the
infrastructure where you you know you're
tapping people's phones or your you know
the stuff is done again boots on the
ground undercover work
obviously going in with cameras makes
your job harder makes your job more
dangerous and i mean rangers
rangers die rangers get killed in this
can you just sort of explain that
explain sort of the risk the
the risks that are just part of this
deal i mean it's it's a very complex
industry especially when you look at
some of these um
you know these corrupted governments and
that's not me pointing fingers at any
specific government or
agency within
um but you do have bad players and in
some of these governments so it makes it
hard you don't know who to trust
um
i think the easiest way to put it to
just lay it out there
when i left tanzania in the wildlife
crimes task force i had a brown recluse
bite on my foot and the local hospital
was like
we can't help you dude you need to go
back to the states so i went back to the
states the guy that took over that task
force
um was assassinated a few months later
in dar salaam two dudes pulled up
on a motorcycle while he was in the back
of a cab
blasted them and took off
it's bad
there have been many assassinations
of individuals and leaders within
conservation those that make a
difference you've got a bounty on your
head because it's such dangerous work
you're also operating i mean granted
you've you you have experience operating
overseas
you know out of the jurisdiction of
obviously the of the states but
i've just heard you know within this
movement you know i have some sort of
family ties to conservationism
especially with animals and and
i've heard that there has been so many
sort of examples of these government
leaders in the in these governments over
there that are sort of like okay yeah
this you know let's bring these people
in let's get the help and then you
realize they're on the take oh dude oh
my god how do you how do you establish a
sense of trust
and i guess the because what i found
really moving and kind of beautiful
about something you said on the show is
that once you are out in the field with
these other rangers once you show hey
dude i'm about walking this walk not
about talking about it then all of a
sudden the bond between you guys yes is
solid as [ __ ] right they get motivated
[ __ ] a they're like these guys are
here these guys are down for this
they're not they're not bullshitters
well they're also wondering where is the
world
where's the world's response
to this crisis and and it's a question
about i mean there was a moment i
believe where you were sort of um
interrogating a a poacher and i want to
talk about like sort of the level one
through five and like how you sort of go
about that because a big thing that we
explore in this show is sort of um
policing in this country and um the sort
of state of policing and you know you
guys are left to deal you know when you
talk about drug cops in this country
there's either guys who are street level
guys are there guys who are sort of city
level guys or they're guys who are sort
of like going after the big dogs and
they have the infrastructure of the
federal government to go about those
things you guys are doing the full
[ __ ] gamut on your own like you're
going after the big dogs you're going
and you're trying to turn people against
each other
one of the things when you were sort of
like talking to these guys is you were
sort of telling them you know what this
is doing to their children to their
country can you just talk about
either you guys talk about
the effects that poaching has on these
countries on the environment as a whole
on the state of sort of like
those societies and how crippling it is
for those places yeah i mean for me it's
i never want to pretend like i've walked
a day in someone else's shoes so i try
to take an empathetic you know
compassion
compassionate approach to everything
even if it is a [ __ ] bag you know what i
mean i i don't i don't know what his
story is maybe we can inspire this guy
to turn it around
um but i'm not god and it's not my job
to judge you and um
and so i just think when you bring that
to the table like man to man do you want
me talking like that to you right like
talking down on you right and drilling
especially if i'm an american in
your country in africa hell no
that's not gonna work um give the guy a
cigarette and hang out talk man to man
educate them a little bit
and and work with them and i believe in
that um it's just not my place i don't
like this um i don't know
villainizing of everybody until i know
their situation you know
i mean there's so much potential when
you think of africa what do you think
like first thing that comes to mind
animals lion king um safaris
that's still an untapped industry over
there
so if we let it get poached out i mean
the potential is gone
um the jobs that are there now are gone
and now you have a
you know a corrupted society a desperate
society and where do criminals thrive
right you know
with desperate people different
desperate situations right and so then
what's next the animals go
the natural resources are already
dwindling
um you know they've been saying africa
is the next battleground for how long
now since the 80s i think they're 70s
and you're gonna see it if we lose
animals and mark where where did you
have you been involved in this since the
beginning like where where did you come
into this
i was putting people undercover in
circuses and wow and where animals are
being abused for the entertainment
industry yeah it just all clicked into
hey i got a couple friends who work in
tv let's see if we can you know help
this cause
um and so i just came into it from there
i just believe you know i spent so much
time with elephants
uh observing them
in captivity
uh being exploited in circuses etc i
mean i've seen them shocked i've seen
them beaten
uh i've seen them exploited by you know
uh people who provide elephants for like
movies like
i don't know what was that one with uh
robert pattinson
the circus one with the elephant uh
i can't remember the name of the movie
but that elephant was highly abused thai
and that's an asian elephant but when i
think about elephants
i get like i just love them that
criminal network that we that we busted
in um
they were part of a network that was
responsible for up to eighteen thousand
unaccounted for elephants [ __ ] yeah you
believe that [ __ ] [ __ ] and right now
your relationship with the tanzanian
government is what
i mean it's there it's a working
relationship we share information
they really want us to come back and
teach it at their ministries college so
we teach um
have you ever heard of human terrain
mapping or behavior pattern recognition
so
no please we're one of the only we are
the only people teaching that in africa
it's basically how to teach law
enforcement and park rangers
how to think like a criminal how to
develop a baseline of someone quickly
just because someone's acting nervous
and fidgety that doesn't mean that
they're hiding something they're
probably just scared because you know
are nervous because an authoritative
figure is coming it doesn't mean you
shoot them or right you know that you
abuse them or you know any of that stuff
and it's something that really needs to
be taught all over the world in law
enforcement because it
it just it's risk mitigation it's
de-escalation of force not letting it
get ramped up
and um actually the first time we taught
that course in africa lin did
on their lunch break they were going up
to the local lodge and they saw eight
guys on the side of the road cutting
grass sometimes that's normal but what
they learned in just the first
the very first person portion of the
course
they saw some cues there and they sure
enough the guys had just thrown their
guns
and their chainsaws and axes over the
fence and they were getting ready to go
poach rhinos wow and they busted them
right there wow without a shot fired
nobody running no abuse nothing wow it
works wow so much of policing in general
is about your relationship with the
community it's about hearts and minds
right it's getting people to say hey
you're better off talking to me
and
i imagine that over there that comes at
extreme risk so how do you mitigate that
and so just first like tell about the
different levels and how do you sort of
attack sure so you have your level one
which is which is your shooter that's
normally just a local
that
has been tracking the animals
and there's no way they can really get
out of it so poachers aren't just poor
people in villages the whole team is
typically a major criminal network and
they send their you know their
protective team in to come in and guard
the shooter while he tracks
the uh the elephant um your next level
is going to be the guy that that the
middleman
he's going to be the guy
that coordinates with the supply and
demand dealer in the big city in africa
and he goes and finds those locals that
are willing to do it
before the network sends in their their
shooters to protect them
after that it's going to be
the person that coordinates from asia to
africa i say asia but the u.s is number
two in
ivory sales
so that's no way i mean we got our
issues too
and then the top guy is the guy that's
making all the money and he's the
kingpin
in asia or the u.s or whatever country
it may be
that's finding the customers for it
getting them exactly what they want and
and making sure that everything goes
smoothly and i imagine that guy is
normally out of country oh yeah and so
like how do you guys i mean is there any
sort of international effort in trying
do you feel like you have international
support for for sort of federal
governments or federal agencies
to who have that sort of infrastructure
targeting those like those big guys
those big wigs it's a good question um
i don't think they've connected the dots
enough at least
you know the bureaucratic leadership
within some of these government agencies
i know the guys that focus from a ground
level
get it
i mean interpol is focusing on it i know
that
the u.s department of state does help us
with some information just to keep us
safe
but it would be nice for the u.s to step
off of this
because the amount of aid that we're
giving some of these countries now it's
going to be a lot more when we lose the
wildlife and laws are changing
in other countries as well well um
they're cracking down they're they're
realizing that it's it's it's not a good
look it's detrimental um
to what they want to do whatever their
agendas is you have to also remember too
that that china makes huge investments
into tanzania
south africa other you know all over the
place there's been chinese government
officials
arrested
for correct me if i'm wrong but
transporting
ivory etc in diplomatic pouches
wow so which are never looked at right
um unless they're radiated unless
they're paying for radiation
which is a new technique in terms of uh
in terms of detecting radiated horns or
whatever or whatever the case may be but
worshiping these majestic animals over
there and loving these and having a
profound sort of respect and reverence
for them how prevalent is that over
there i think with park rangers
in most cases and i'm talking
most like 99 of the time
um i believe them to be doing the job uh
for passion for wildlife protecting
their heritage i mean if you look at the
money
in most countries in
you know east africa in the southern
hemisphere of africa they have animals
on their on their
on their currency and like you show that
to somebody and you're like hey this is
your heritage
like how embarrassing is that going to
be for your generation
when you know your kids kids kids
you know the animals are gone for them
right we read this book one of our board
members um
lulu was a rhino and it was inspired by
his first trip to africa with us jason
flom wrote it and so we try to go into
the schools and teach the kids you know
it's a good way to just connect with
them but if you teach a kid at a young
age like hey no that that animal
like that's an icon right um that's
that's where it starts educating the
youth
um
i i just the youth is empowering
economies and educating people what
what's the money ratio
like how much if you compared the money
that's made by animal tourism
versus poaching
what's that
do you have any idea what that is it's
so disproportionate because it's only a
handful of people making money off of
poaching whereas a whole lodge
eco-friendly lodge you know supplies 50
to 100 there's way more money and one is
sustainable one is it exactly so and
that's part of the argument also to
winning the hearts and minds it's like
what are you guys doing like you you're
literally you're killing off the
resource yep
economic it's it's not even close what's
crazy is every time a rhino is poached
the value of that horn is going to go up
on the black market because there's less
of them it's more rare right right so
it's like they're literally poaching
these animals to extinction let's just
talk about a little bit um
you know if you if you guys don't mind
just sort of
the in the field the level of danger for
you guys in the field i've been to
africa i was there you know with my
family we went on safari and also i mean
it was most profound experience of my
life by far was just being able to be
out there among those animals um
you know while we were there we we had
an accident and
the
there's no way you can
describe to people who haven't been
there how profoundly alone and and like
you are [ __ ] [ __ ] if anything bad
happens you are [ __ ] it's not like hey
we're like 30 minutes or an hour a
couple hours from the hot it's like it's
not gonna happen man there is no way to
get there in time and um you know we we
like we we really experienced that and
you know you're going out there with
people shooting at you well that's why
that's why that was so ironic about the
first mission was you know you guys are
out there doing the work
you can get shot at you get hit with a
[ __ ] bow and arrow whatever the case
may be but it was a spider
that yeah that kind of brought you down
you know what i mean so the dangers the
dangers minuscule or
you know what i mean yeah i mean you
also have well i mean minuscule in terms
of like it comes in a small body it's a
dangerous i mean it's a dangerous place
for people to be period yep yeah
i mean matt kunkel got attacked by a
cape buffalo and lived it to tell about
it nobody does that
he's a strong man guy right have you
ever seen um
uh dodgeball with yeah or the he's got
the painting of him fighting the bull
yeah this is literally what he did for
almost an hour so is that a loan
because he was here
uh he's actually in uh us army stuff
yeah
and and so what happened was it a load i
heard that like the lone male cape
buffalo because like in a herd right
they're not that dangerous but if you
get one by himself it's like very
dangerous isn't that right yeah one or
two um
he actually so he matt was checking a
fence line the voltage on a fence and
there was a guy from another
organization that was supposed to be
catching his back and matt had my
beautiful awesome 308 rifle with a
really nice piece of glass on it and the
buffalo launched that over the fence
like 40 feet in the air
and uh now he had puncture winds right
so did he just sneak up on him he didn't
no no it was driving him into the ground
he was wrestling this thing
for almost an hour
but he's a strong man competitor wow if
it was me i'd be dead if there was any
one of us here we'd be dead wow
and the d and
and so how did that uh how does that end
uh so i wasn't there for it i actually
woke up in the middle of night i was in
the u.s fundraising and i get a whatsapp
message and all it said was
hey matt got attacked by a buffalo or on
the way to the hospital yeah and i woke
up to this what in the hell yeah it's
like a nightmare yeah ryan gets a lot of
these texts i bet
i've talked to people as you guys know
like i talked to my dad my dad used to
be the
chairman of the board of the humane side
of the united states and he would tell
me that
there were groups that were kind of
similar to you guys
that
were
sort of not welcomed because it was
looked at as these are
americans especially white americans
coming into these places
how do you navigate that what are your
thoughts on that um it seems to me that
clearly your guys
hearts are with not just with these
animals but with the communities have
you guys come in contact with that and
to what degree has that been racial
believe it or not i'll plant this seed
and i'll leave it there for you know
another time but it was uh there was a
very famous
uh american celebrity whose brother
had a corrupt program going on and he
decided that he wanted to get a tv
production
nobody would give him a tv production
because we were already in the market
and we're a real organization not a tv
production right and so he decided to go
and stick his fingers in in places and
manipulate things behind her back which
which i haven't forgotten about so
love to run into him one day um
but there was a lot of politicians yeah
that happened there in terms of in terms
of that mission i don't know don't say
anything you guys don't want to say
like i just want to get sued you know
because what i saw again and it's sort
of a continual theme that we hit on this
show the guys on the ground who are
actually doing the work
[ __ ] love you guys you guys are like
brothers in arms you guys are like
totally synced in mission but then
you've got these folks who aren't on the
ground who aren't in the field that are
having problems with it those people are
easily manipulated if you've actually
been in the like down the road with
somebody and you're actually in the
field with somebody it's a lot harder to
manipulate them you know there's there's
a camaraderie and a brotherhood there
well let me just say this from my
observation
nobody did this really before
vetpaw utilizing the skills of post 911
veterans right
which are taxpayer-funded skills that go
to waste so part of ryan's vision was
how can we utilize those skills that
american taxpayers are paying for and
have an impact on protecting
endangered species you had an amputee
come out wow he lost his leg in
afghanistan came out the guy's scaling
walls literally like
wall played with with his prosthetic on
riding dirt bikes this guy left a battle
a combat zone on a stretcher and a
helicopter not on his own terms now we
gave him an opportunity
he earned his opportunity
to come out to africa and leave a new
area of operation on his own terms
that's healing i think beautiful and
then he went on to get his masters and
yeah you know so
there's there's there's there's
something about this organization that
even when it's ups and downs changes
the the lives hopefully for the better
of the people who work for it yeah
what is the vetting process what is the
selection process obviously and and then
what is the what's the training
sure um so at all it all is based on
you know the missions needs at the time
in terms of how many guys that we invite
men and women we've had women go through
it as well
um
but it's tough i mean we're not here to
you know put you through boot camp again
we've all done that i don't have time
for that i want to do that crap
so we wear you out mentally and
physically
you've got to go through a physical
fitness test you got to go through land
nav night nav um you got to go through
uh rifle shooting pistol shooting um
uh did i say medical yet
field medicine um and then human terrain
mapping and behavior pattern recognition
you get an introduction to that
you have to whoever finishes top you get
priority when deployment
deployments open up
we're not a
you know guns for hire we're not coming
out to film a tv production otherwise we
wouldn't still be there you see a lot of
those ngos you see some veterans that go
out there they do some filming
they break a lot of walls on camera too
and then they can never come back we're
still there
and people need to see
that we're not cops in the bush people
need to come out and see what we're
doing you can come out and visit our our
host reserve where our headquarters is
you're incredibly safe you have u.s
veterans always around you get a
hands-on experience like no other you're
not bumping into tourists everywhere you
know if there's elephants there's not a
traffic jam of safari vehicles right
you're spending time with the veterans
around the fire at night
hearing their story
and then you become part of our family
can you talk about the relocation
project though and and yeah and how many
baby rhinos have you know come out of
that and i mean not specific numbers but
yeah so we have had i want to say a 30
increase in black rhinos since we
relocated them there
naturally through breeding
elephants well our populations are
exploding but but with the black rhinos
we're set to move 100
black rhinos into our reserve from high
risk areas we moved the first 18 then
covet hit so now we're looking to do
that again we move them upside down
underneath the huey
and
into the reserve they're asleep it's the
safest way actually i think was it
stanford one of the big schools
deemed it's the safest way to move on is
upside down wow so it's trippy seeing
you know it's basically like a chevy
suburban yeah upside down underneath a
huey it's wild yeah i mean it's
i have to say the pictures wow
um so there's that i mean we're a
non-profit so awareness is so important
that's why we appreciate the opportunity
being on the on your show that's a big
deal for us donations are great we're
not
a lot of people see our social media and
they think we've you know got all this
this big funding we're not even a
million dollar organization to do what
we do with a million dollars a year is
insane nobody else can do it
go and find him i dare you you won't
we don't have an endowment we're hand to
mouth we want to work on an endowment um
but so every donation goes to supporting
those guys on the ground every penny and
and when you said you could come out and
visit the reserve so like
uh you're a travel agent right now man
tell me like you know what's that uh
what's that like we can do ops
observation points up in the mountains
um if we're doing a an operation a
medical operation procedure on a
on an animal you get to participate in
that so if we dart a rhino because we
have to re-collar it for tracking
purposes or check the health after it's
been relocated to the reserve you've got
to check those hormone levels and things
like that or dehorn or uh yeah we don't
do dehorning on our reserve um
we're not against it it's just it's we
believe it's starting to change the
genetics you can actually cut the horn
of a rhino off without going through the
flesh but it takes a team of people
um
to make them less appealing to poachers
but if a poacher tracks a dehorn rhino
and finds that it doesn't have a horn
they'll shoot it anyway so they don't
continue tracking it
so it's [ __ ] in other [ __ ] dude
yeah it's scum
uh and the horn grows back it's like
but it's starting to affect the the gene
pool or the the behavior patterns
because the males can't bully the
females anymore okay so they're not
breeding as much so now what do we do
got it so it's um
[ __ ] horn man yeah and the experience
is for is for the average person who
who's passionate about
conservation passionate about the kind
of animals that you've seen
um and and it's called the vet
experience right basically and and so
you get a two-week opportunity
to
really be hands-on in what it takes
to
keep these animals protected thriving
uh and
and and diverse and how do you go about
finding so you go on um vetpal.org org
and we have an experience tab on there
um and you just fill out the the form on
there uh we do check some social media
you know we want to make sure you're not
you know i'm not your therapist so if
you're coming to africa with us um yeah
we've we i don't want to sit around fire
and you know listen to your problems all
night no offense but um
but yeah we make sure it's the right
people you know when you're coming out
there yeah all the money that you paid
goes back into the mission but we need
you returning back to the states and
being an ambassador for us and spreading
awareness for what we do
and um
yeah it's just got to be the right
people right on
guys i just i i really really appreciate
you guys being here uh i i have so much
uh respect for for what you all did and
i just want to let you know you know you
you got you got a friend in in me and
anything that i can do anything that we
can be helpful with or as much as i
could be a part of things please never
never ever hesitate oh yeah man you're
like exactly
the kind of guys that we we want to
celebrate and and uh just thank you
thank you for what you do thank you for
who you are i really appreciate you guys
doing appreciate it yeah we need more
guys like you man it's awesome to use
your platform for this we we appreciate
it and dude you gotta come to africa i'm
done deal you tell me when deal we're
gonna make it happen i'll change your
life i'm a hundred percent comfortable
i'm saying that on [ __ ] yeah josh is
coming i'm 100 [ __ ] coming thank you
fellas i really appreciate this result
our pleasure it's a real honor guys
thank you likewise appreciate it
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff it'd mean a lot to us
i hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself